sophie turner and joe jonas are
expecting baby number two and now a
source tells e.t that the lovebirds are
over the moon i'm pumped i'm ready
sophie and joe were overjoyed to learn
they are expecting a second child of
course the two are already parents to
one-year-old daughter willa whom they
welcomed in july 2020. and e.t source
notes that both sophie and joe have
siblings and didn't want their little
girl to be an only child adding that
they have always talked about having a
bigger family i'm so excited about it
and while they have yet to announce the
news publicly the 26 year old game of
thrones star's baby bump has been on
full display during recent outings with
her man that sophie last month in la
rocking red locks with a green dress and
flats looking full on maternity chic
love blush are you blushing oh god yeah
or i'm sweaty i can't tell and one thing
is for sure sophie loves being a mama
last year she celebrated uk mother's day
by thanking joe and their beautiful baby
girl on her instagram story for making
her a mom quote it's my favorite job
i've ever had and joe
he loves it too it means so much to have
him here it's just like the best support
i'm so happy that he's here last may the
32 year old musician opened up about
home life with his wife and daughter
amid the pandemic during an appearance
on cbs this morning it's been amazing um
this
it's been forced time at home you know i
think i'm always on the go i'm always
moving and traveling and touring
and to be in one place for a solid
amount of time and just have my feet on
the ground and be with my family my
immediate family and um is time i i
don't think i'll i'll get back and so i
i'm so thankful and grateful baby number
two for sophie and joe only extends the
jobro brood joe's older brother kevin
jonas has two daughters valentina and
elena while younger bro nick jonas and
his wife priyanka chopra welcomed their
first child back in january via a
surrogate it's been an incredible
incredible ride a source at the time
told et that the two are quote so happy
and settling into parenthood nicely it's
a special thing quote priyanka and nick
always wanted to have children together
priyanka is very maternal and has wanted
to be a mother for a long time they were
determined to have a baby no matter what
um babies as many as god would give us
and e.t source added quote this is
something they've both really wanted so
they're thrilled and appreciative my
life is very good right now very excited
priyanka kinda sorta hinted that they
were expecting back in november during
the jonas brothers family rose special
we are the only couple
who doesn't have kids yet
which is why i'm excited to make this
announcement
sorry babe
nick and i are expecting
to get drunk tonight and sleep in
tomorrow
oh your face was really funny when i
said that well they may not be sleeping
much anymore but one thing is for sure
nick and priyanka are one seriously
solid duo it was kind of an instant
thing knew once we locked in together
that i had a partner for life and a
teammate something i could walk through
the good times and bad times with and
that was that was the key
yeah i'm blushing now
[Music]